hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast size matters accurate
detection and phasing of structural
variations presented by Fritz Sibley
check pH D lead scientific programmer
baylor college of medicine i am k lee
baca black boots and i will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box and
click send will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Silva check he will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome I wanna
thank you very much for giving me the
opportunity percent over and before we
dive into the matter I figured I should
just if you prefer a few of mine my
group scientific interest so my group is
mainly into are mainly interested in
developing algorithms for mapping and
assembling short and long tweets but
also very much in the direction of
variants such as structure variants
although all we are leveraging our
knowledge that we obtained with
benchmarking studies to determine which
signals are true or false and I'm very
happy and unfortunate to collaborate
with many peoples to study human model
organisms all the non-model organisms
across the globe
a broad topic today is about structure
balance so our understanding about
structure rounds is really driven by
technologies being it laid in 1942 1980s
but it could identify losses or gains of
chromosome arms or karyotyping until
near early 2000s where we had
microarrays at our hand but we could
take copy number variations of certain
machines but really just friends with
the start of 2008-2009 the advance of
short resequencing such as alumina we
get more and more knowledge about those
structure variants in the frequency and
today I will argue that single molecule
sequencing such as the part bio system
but also the Nano persistent believe
broaden all understanding of structure
variants in the human genomes and also
other organisms structure rounds are
generally very important in among
different aspects of medicine and
biology being an evolutionary context
where we can for example speak about
gene gains and shin dusters genomic
disorders such as mindydyan diseases or
just recently as cancer that we couldn't
be writing up application Escamilla free
where we investigated genomic disorders
and therefore the amplification of
certain oncogenes being the impact of
structure burns and regulatory units
were unfortunate to work together with
gtex and encode consortium and as well
as of course phenotypic changes and that
are also influenced by structure grants
as a as I showed on the recent
publication and beginning of 2017 but
giving a coating in step back how do we
actually detect structure around so this
is basic just a very naive view here
across the five types of structure
rounds that we observe being in
tunisians insertions are people
attending to applications and versions
and translocations and B often can
detect those over present distance or
parent reads such as from the Illumina
machine where we observe abnormal
distances or abnormal orientation of the
two pairs furthermore we can leverage a
split rate signals
spirits are and two reaches or more of
the same read and map to different
regions of the chromosome and by that we
can pretty much nail down where the
breakpoints are and which kind of type
or which type of structure runs we
observe however today we are going to
folk
as long we technology such as papaya and
monopole I'm going to show you by so
they have different advantages such as
we can observe structure events and
repetitive regions where it's generally
very hard to map those short routes into
they can span the structure and mean we
can follow the continuous sequence of
stroke of the read food structure around
rather than observing kind of a pattern
of AutoCAD entries they have more
uniform courage less bias and GC regions
for example and as I'm going to show you
today that you can identify even more
complex structure and symbol for life
types that are showed in the previous
slide however we have to cope with two
challenges first of all they're too much
higher sequencing error rate and
aluminum and the length plus the
sequencing error it makes it really hard
to align so the centralized question
today is really can how can be fully
leveraged to technologies and I'm going
to talk about first improving of the
alignment of those reads and improvement
about structuration calling which is the
problem sniffles I'm going to show you
some regulation and results that they
haven't real data in the end I'm going
to talk about how can we extend this
work and leverage this technology source
for larger cohorts giving them more
expensive technologies so the first part
I'm always asked for developing methods
on your algorithms is do we actually
need them so always the first question
is why another method we have arrays so
many short reads and quite a few long
with nippers so here I'm showing you an
HIV screenshot of PW and then Peter mmm
is among one of the few standard methods
for long reads and what we can see here
is basically we have different tweets
plotted in on the screen lines and we
see a lot of noise going on so we see a
lot of colors so every color represents
four excessive for example substitutions
receive purple color which is insertions
and we see this black lines which are
actually short deletions and we kind of
wonder what is what is going on this
region for real when we do when we map
the same rate so if our new method ng/ml
are we basically see that we can replace
this noisy pattern with a kind of very
comprehensive looking deletion which is
homozygous and we can see that by these
black lines going through the image here
is a predicted length
let's do another example for example
this one again we see with b/w memories
see cat a very nice pattern in terms of
colors we see a lot of mismatches we see
again this little lines popping up which
indicate divisions so maybe it's the
same type as as previously but actually
when we mapped the same breeds and
actually with a lower runtime we see
that the middle block is actually
inverted so this would be an inversion
instead of a deletion in previous slide
and freely so we focused on on the HTML
are basically on improving two parts
first of all Esprit treats to enhance
the mapping across translocations and
versions and duplications and then also
improve the alignment itself which
should enable us to better map out
insertions and deletions and all of this
work is really done by Philipp ruch
Nader who was a former colleague of mine
back in Vienna so I want to dive in
shortly how we do that so for the split
reads we do the following scheme nary
pipeline so we have a long week we split
them up in 256 base pairs just for sake
of an example we assume that the orange
part is so difficult to map region maybe
it's a repetitive Ridge or very high
noise ratio from errors then we use the
short route mapper entry and that we
developed over my PhD back in Vienna to
map all of these subsequence are to the
reference genome next we make a
catalogue of various subsequence of
mapping this 256 base per sub segments
and we see for example the blue arrow is
mapping it location 1500 with in London
score of 99 we see that the orange part
which is a little more tricky is mapping
to multiple locations but not very well
giving the indication of the alignment
score so therefore this this part is
ignored but a creep odd Reseda is
mapping in two places very well about in
one place it's kind of shady so that for
the third place is ignored so on so
forth so next you want to reconcile
these things so here we just show the
plot of the readers we observed it on
the y-axis versus the location of the
subsequence of the 256 base pairs on the
x-axis on the on the reference genome so
first thing that we observe quite
curious which parts of the breeds are
next to each other on the read as well
as on the reference you know in here
this is for example a gray in the green
arrow and therefore we can group those
things together one segment the next
part is we can see that the blue the
grey arrow is actually equally distance
on the read and on the reference due to
the missing of a good mapping of the
orange part so you can again reconcile
these things so next is getting a little
bit more challenging because now we have
to distinguish if we trust the orange
arrow or if you trust those free arrows
on the right side and for that we
compute the paris distances of those
alignments and based on the alignment
score and the information how they are
aligning together the dynamic
programming approach we can reconcile
that that this for example is the
correct answer to where this read is
mapping to and how this read is mythic
and but let me see that the green arrow
here actually indicates the small red
version so now we are good with retreats
but how do we improve the alignment
itself that was the first case rápido
England showed us very noisy Alumnus
Tunisia for example so doing a pairwise
alignment between sequences have basic
healed more or less like three different
modes first of all the linear suits
Waterman or Needleman wound shot almost
all of us learned during college in
computer science the thing kept cost
model accounts for an opening versus an
extension of a gap therefore reflects
better the biological signal and
therefore is used for most of the
mappers right now what we propose is the
convex cap cost I'm going to show you
Alice's so for the think at cost since
we have this long reads we have to take
into account that we have single base
pair insertion and deletion
sequencing errors and quite a couple of
those so for this given example I'm
showing here we basically end up with
two equally likely scenarios from the
fingered cost model being the upper one
where we have like one two three four
five six and single insertions and
deletions and maybe one deletion in the
read itself on the Lord like the other
alignment proposed
that we have one two three larger ones
and just fewer sequencing errors so
given the knowledge that this that the
dominant sequencing error from the
machines are single insertion deletions
we know that the upper alignment is more
likely and here is that comes that comes
the convex gothic Austin to play like
the convex cap cause basically assigns
different scoring schemes depending on
the length of the observed event and but
that we can finally achieve that
automatically the upper limit is chosen
because it has a high alignment score so
now that we proved or improve the split
read netting as well as how was mapping
it on its own I can show you some real
simulations and emulation how these
things improve things so for that resume
elated using survivor which is the tool
adele developed twenty structure burns
of different types and different size
regimes and today i'm just going to show
you the results over the park pilot
simulated treats and related networks
such as plays a bit of in minecraft
nippon and Chimel are basically the
relation is based on this little screen
shot on the right there for example a
division if it's mapped out correctly by
each of the meet meaning corresponding
breakpoints so there's no noise in the
middle then we call this read correct in
that we call every chromium app if there
is a nice pattern or different matches
across the tunisian Custis is not
indicating the deletion at all and we
call a read indicated so a yellow
if the breakpoints a little fussy but
overall we can make out that there is a
deletion in between so here are
different bar plots on the x-axis you
see the size regimes of the structure
rounds and again we simulated twenty
structure burns pair bar and on the
y-axis you see the percentage of reads
so red means that the reaper basically
aligned through here in desertion and
conditions yellow means the indicated
part crane means lift just part of the
read was aligned but not continuously
through the insertion or deletion and
bite means that the region all in line
so all we see that ng/ml are really
improves our ability to map those reads
across insertion deletion
mainly because of this comebacks kept
cost function for other types of
variants we still see an improvement
across multiple types and much more size
regimes compared to other members only
in the case with a very small base pairs
of translocations so here for example
100 base pair translocations we see that
we cannot precisely map those out but in
reality we don't don't expect it sort of
this kind of type very off so next part
of my presentation is stabbing into
instructure brands so now we have this
enhanced Network we of course want to
leverage should better signal to metal
structure rounds
however again I want to show you why we
actually need another structure
variation collar so first of all we want
of course to leverage these data sets
and this mapping for all types of
structure rounds or deletions tandem
duplications insertions inversion
translocations we also needed a better
method to cope with still artifacts of
sequencing errors or PCR and the
structure version color that I'm
presenting here sniffles is really also
able to detect more complex types of
variations so for example here I'm
showing you on the right and inverted
tandem duplication where a molecule goes
from right to left chumps
back a little bit and continues towards
the right and we can see that this is
this can be nice in that with long waits
however in the short retract which is in
the law we see that the hair ends as
plus or split with larger fragments but
we don't see the overall signal of
destruction and and this types of
structure lines are still important
because they are associated with
different diseases for example the neck
neck p2 and B power 2 and we have also
more complex other events I'm going to
show you that also associated with
different disease phenotypes so I'm very
pre for Dustin if will do and we
basically analyzes the Spree treats the
alignment events dispersed in noisy
regions so with noisy regions we mean
signals such as we saw from Peter
remember through first slides it does a
parameter estimation to adopt itself
automatically two part bio data as well
as nanopore data and it can detect
sequence and artifacts and therefore
contacts it optional it provides
you know typing estimation and
registering of phasing of structure
burns if TR kills together so again I'm
using the same simulated results this
time be a benchmarking against different
structuration callers so survivor is
basically a consensus color which uses
lumpy DeLeon mentors of free short reads
call it based call us today that I ran
for this data sets a BB Hani was
previously used based on blazer
alignment crossed about bio reads and
then we have sniffles with PWM N and
sniffles with pepper and similar and be
sealed sniffles compared to the other
members already enhance our ability to
detect in dusk or actually so precise he
really means that breakpoint has to be
within blast miles 10 base pairs to be
callers precise otherwise it would be
indicated which allows up to 1 KB
distance of the simulated prey point but
also for other types such as
duplications translocations and
inversions we see that sniffles really
improve the ability to call these events
and even just based on padorin only in
the scenario where we have a 100 base
pair tandem duplication we have a yellow
bar and this is because the distal
occasions actually called as an
insertion and with this slide I'm just
recap the rating that that application
actually means that the same sequence is
inserted next to each other therefore I
would argue at the hundred base for
insertion call here is not too bad
more interestingly are the more complex
type of events for example the inversion
of Frank but deletions or the tandem and
verda tandem duplications are surely
previously so here's again HIV
screenshot how an inversion think this
to deletion looks like so the middle
segment here is an inverted segment
flanked by two heterozygous traditions
here and here all these free events can
be precisely called with an Shyamalan
sniffles however other callers like the
ability to identify the whole complexity
of this region we see but a parent is
about a short reach parents that the
inversion is supported but we don't have
and don't have enough signal to detect
those initial start of flanking it and
again this inversion of flanked by
deletions of bear
in fact that was associated with a blood
clotting disorder in 2007 for the model
inversion tenant application at a
shortly before this also now Abyan are
able to collect this on high precision
using HTML are together with sniffles
which wasn't it being able to be to be
detected previously so next I want to
dive into some real results are some
real data results and revelation for
those two methods so again we are using
survivor and this time not just on the
short read data but also comparing a
different structure Asian Kazakh within
a sample so survivor is really just a
general tool kit was that allows us to
simulate and evaluate structure Asians
and structuration colors it allows the
comparison the merging of multiple
structure Beijing call sets being if if
in the samples or across the samples and
it also has several other tools for
example to summarize what structure
burns are called or what size regimes
are called so the first example I want
to dive into is of obviously a trio
where we can leverage atom in Dillian
and inheritance and here we got data
from calcium which is actually the
reference of our Dobson's cv i0 so very
distance cultivar from our adopters
compared to the reference and then we
also sequence the f1 cross of both
parents and you can see there we have
quite prestigious coverage for all three
data sets as these data sets were taken
from the [ __ ] on state paper so the
first question is of course which
structure barons are homozygous lee
found in the call zero but are not found
in the f1 generation which would
indicate an error in the calling so
overall we identified fifty-seven
structure ends being homozygous in the
COS 0 the number so low because that's
again what i said is the reference
genome lecture the reference cultivar of
our adopters so initially using sniffles
and ng/ml are we missed for structure
variants out of this 57 and these were
two different reasons so first of all
they had an insertion and addition that
are called as a fifty-three base per
event in the cost zero but then they are
in fair
as 47 base Burman and 48 bears bear
amended the f1 and the cutoff for the
length by default and sniffles was 50
base per but we could be identified and
once we lowered the size threshold and
then we had another case two other cases
where we had add additional and tenant
application that also only supported by
four reads in this region and we lowered
again the courage threshold that
sniffles useless but I thought we were
able to identify so all we could
identify all the structure grounds that
the Hamasaki protected in cozier in the
f1 successfully and more tricky scenario
is to see the IOC VI is a very distant
cultivar to the reference genome of our
topsis therefore we found over 10,000
structure bands to be homozygous in this
variety initially we missed 370 which
means as missing rate of 3 point 6 2
percent false negative 3 of 6 3 point 6
2 percent and this had although again
different reason regions are reasons
like in the previous slide so first of
all we identified almost 1/2 those
events had too low read support so and
lowering the Thresher we could
identified easily 101 events had
actually a sized threshold problem like
previously shown low slightly below 50
base books for the three of those events
were indicated by different size about
different types for example when
transposons are called this can be an
insertion of a transposon or it can be
represented as a as a reinsertion as the
movement of the transpose into a
different region but we could resolve
the below in the type constraint and
then we also took the calls here at the
CBI a de novo assembly that we got from
Falcon and step and investigated those
kills indeed find 50 regions where we
missed structure variants and where it
seems to that the f1 doesn't have the
corresponding region of the CBI presence
genome so we ended up with only 17 1 1 7
structure and said we could not really
define dare form cross which is a
successor of 99.8%
so next I'm going to dive into some
human data you used to anyone to
inseminate because it's like the gold
standard in genomics it's a healthy
female and the very interesting aspect
here was it was sequence with many
technologies and getting from the
Illumina but bio as far as Oxford
nanopore so in literally this is the
table to Australian initial call set and
we had very encouraged between those
different technologies of 55 X or papaya
but only 2080 x fox or nano port and 50x
coverage for Illumina and also what I
have to say it as far as to the
bacterial status is little bit older and
other datasets so the first thing that
was interesting to see this actually ad
for Oakland a Nepali almost observed
27,000 divisions which seems a little
bit high so we dived into this data and
looked at some examples and here's one
of those screenshots so in a lower track
you see the Oxford nanopore data in the
middle tracked part bio data in the
upper track the Illumina reads how
they're mapping to you and we see here
that we observe like 3 deletions in this
short region based on the Oxford
nanopore data and we see that neither
backed by an or in luminous support any
of those deletions just cancel fissures
and what we also saw is that all three
of those deletions happen actually in
low complexity region which indicated to
us that this is probably based calling
artifact from Oxford nanopore and that
was also suggested by a recent
publication that came out recently over
this Oxford nanopore data and Oxford
nanopore is indeed working on this
problem and almost resolved up to now in
the meantime we also sequenced the same
sample here at the Baylor College of
Medicine up to 34 X coverage we see that
the deletion counts really reduced
through 27,000 to 7,000 much more in
line from what we see from the bio data
sets of all we were very interested in
the performance of the insertions and
deletions especially because we had very
problems I'm calling insertions over the
humeral data with data sets and also had
discrepancy between the Illumina
datasets and along with datasets in
terms of numbers of events yes for
example one region where nanopore and
papaya agrees on a deletion we see a
drop in coverage of indicating
Indonesian in Illumina however this
slide was not picked up by any of our
Chaudhary structuration colors that we
applied here which was meant Italian
lumpy free of the most commonly used
structuration colors looking for short
read data so what we what we did to
approach this and to ask question how
can we assess if the event a lot of
other long reads was really supported in
the short reads or not was the following
kind of straightforward idea so given
that we have had entries for the short
reads can we can estimate what we can
measure the average insert size of these
parents which in this case was around
300 Levin base pairs if there is a
division event happening this distance
between the two pairs is significantly
in reach and large if there is an
insertion happening and then two pairs
are moving closer together until the
second pair for example is inside of the
insertion definitely so by using this we
use the two-sided t-test to assess this
are giving calls from the long retailer
over the prepared end distance in the
short read data and assess additions
from 50 base but the freaking Assad
regime and insertions from 50 paise per
to 300 base pay the 300 base pair was
teaching that if the insertion were
longer than 300 base but a second pair
wouldn't have been mapped and here the
results for this we use the p-value of
0.01 or smaller to call something
significant interestingly giving the
initial calls from Bubba higher or could
monopod with sniffles and ng/ml are we
were able to identify much more
significant additions than with actually
luminal cost and when comparing the
purple and the Nevada desert we
identified at 84 percent of traditions
where on increment as well as 46% of 47%
of
insertion or for the coverage levels
were almost hard for Manipur compared to
abide by the last chapter I want to
touch base on this anyone to inseminate
cause it was the translocations of D&D
cause translocations are again
indications that a molecule spends from
one chromosome to another chromosome and
this is very important for example
canceled studies so out of so Illumina
all free callers agreed that we had two
thousand two hundred forty-seven
translocation caused resin but bio for
example we just found one hundred twenty
and I want to show you one of those
regions that really represented lots of
those scenarios so we see here the
Illumina data we see multiple reads
colored here that are indicating
translocation so the second pair of
those reads are mapped to a different
chromosome however we're pulling the but
by order Oxford nanopore data we see in
both datasets independently that there
is an insertion event going on in a low
complexity region which actually
highlights and repeat expansion rather
than the transportation when we look
back in the Illumina data we actually
see I hope you can see that that the
reads are truncated indicated by this
red stripe in the end and therefore also
more pointing towards an insertion event
rather than a translocation event
because if there would be a
translocation event the reads would be
split and the second path to read would
be aligned on the different chromosome
so by characterizing this we can of
course quantify how often these events
happen and actually all of this 2247
translocation events 53 percent of them
are just this scenario varies observe a
repeat expansion rather than a
translocation overall we had multiple as
in areas where we had different it's
called but this insertion artifact seems
to be really the dominant cause of this
force cause in a short retail of course
this is not trust happening for
translocation events but we also observe
the similar scenario for inversions but
with lower frequency so here again for
inversions I'm showing you the reads
colored in blue and two keys that in the
version of Mentalist half that reads a
map to a different location with
different orientation and again in this
low complexity scenario you see an
insertion happening indicated by the pad
pile and from the actual nanopore data
independently so all of these tools and
all these technologies are working
pretty nicely right now still we have
the problem that sitting on these
technologies are rather pricey compared
to the short read data so therefore we
are currently working on on the question
like how can we apply this long retainer
in a cost-effective cost-effective
manner in larger cohorts and for that we
are looking at the CCD chip data where
multiple sequencing centers including
ours sequence up to 20,000 600
individuals whole genome sequence and
repeating neato studies because we want
to identify what are common over rare
structure bands in the population by
that indicating and for example the risk
of a pathogenic variant we want to have
this structure well called catalogs
across different ethnicities and
different phenotypes to inform cheaver
studies of course all the necessary
specific structuration catalog is
something that would be very nice to
achieve and also we were interesting of
course the variability of certain
regions that for medical relevance such
as the MHC in a pain region for Muslim 6
and on the lower track I'm showing you a
density plot across chromosome 6 plot
ideally frequency on the y-axis and the
position across chromosome 6 and x axis
and we see hots common hotspot such as
the MHC where we have multiple alleles
that are shared among individuals what
is what was also interesting to see was
that when the inside of the chromosomes
in the middle region of the chromosome
he also had much bodies with shared
structure bands across the population
which indicates that not just MHC might
be very tricky might be very highly
variable but also other regions among
thousand six and also most whole genome
however was the short potater
it is often reported that
we are lacking sensitivity so missing a
lot of structure grounds as indicated by
the tables that I showed you today also
we have the problem of false positives
and meaning falsely called structure
runs as a just gave you the example for
this impede extensions versus
translocations or inversions so
therefore being working on the strategy
and how to select subsamples out of this
large cohort to be sequences long reads
to not just validate those structure
baron-cohen appear though structure and
calls that we observed over the
chaudhary data but further inform
structure and cost structure rounds to
be maybe have missed and by that we i've
implemented a framework on kind of a 3d
selection of samples the cool thing here
is that we can choose samples very
efficiently and therefore be also very
price efficient so basically what I did
here is I took from this twenty two
thousand six hundred samples that took
out four thousand four hundred samples
that we have actually sampled DNA data
at at the HTS C and then ask a question
or can I select those samples are given
the initial structuration calls to
obtain the most from all for the
management and the important kerf is on
the lower left where as the fraction of
the structure burns captured so this is
calculated back to the overall
population of the four thousand four
hundred and the number of samples that
be selected this is up to a hundred and
the interesting thing is that if you are
selecting a hundred samples so this is
three percent around three percent of
the samples of this whole sub-cohort we
can validate 50 percent of the structure
variance in this data set so this is a
very efficient way to validate a large
number of structure burns another
interesting fact is that this framework
automatically selected the most number
of samples to be from african-american
followed by Hispanic and the
implications but also doesn't require
this information so it also selected
five samples were collected and if the
information in this Court
so it's another uninformed way of
selecting samples and giving them
getting them best the most of it for
in terms of validation and what we are
currently doing with this is we're
hunting for his comprehensive genomes
and the swallowing pipeline by using
ng/ml orifice we detect structure burns
of Oxford nanopore or Arpaio and then we
are using tection omics and using the
long range of pipeline to face the
structure brands together with the slips
to be over and he called in the CCG cord
and is phasing together is done over the
head to pad man
and then this merged structure Behrens
from the long reads with the link reads
together with the faced snip information
from that bit to is put together into
cross stitch cross which is a program
that is kundi implemented all with
Polish at slab and trans Hopkins
University and but that we obtained a
haplotype resolve snips and
structuration list and can also read
this really identify the whole she know
as a father certificate fast afar and
then we are working on how to
reintroduce the computational genotype
to snips and structure variants in the
larger cohort of CCD gene and we already
did that for four samples right now and
we are processing where I'd notice
hundred samples that we selected by the
frame vector represents in a previous
slide and I'm just going to show you
some very brief results of your plane so
first result here is based on phasing of
snips and structure ends together again
on chromosome six chromosome six is very
interesting to us because it contains
image C and LPA so for the Ashkenazi son
that we run here we obtained a DNA
molecule length for the 10x genomics
which is almost a hundred K P so this is
really an optimal scenario using bio we
obtained a co dot two megabytes and
fifty phasing careful with the 10x
genomics long range of pipeline this
wasn't proof but a ten-piece to to
compare that DNA are the longer T
inequality however praval pipeline with
all optimized parameters we actually can
bumped it up to 67 mph phase and fifty
facing lengths and what the spring see
is basically two phasing clocks pair
chromosome chromosome arm
some six facing completely free MHC and
as well as LP however in a different
data set age as one oh one one we had
not that prestigious DNA quality and
therefore the end fifty facing of course
dropped significantly you are just able
to get barely one and be and fifty
facing blocks you're still able to face
some regions and language see and other
regions is still informative well it's
not as prestigious that we got from the
different I support a different sample
and this also indicates the variability
in the and the necessity for his phasing
approaches giving a prestigious T
inequality so one of the last slides
that I want to show you is a deletion
actually identified over there but bio
data sets and we also have our Nasik
datasets and for those samples the
interesting part of this deletion is
first of all isn't
intergenic space second of all was not
identified potential objects so we see
that ages 101 one has a heterozygous
deletion indicated essence red are here
for anyone to accelerate the healthy
female be observed a homozygous deletion
interestingly when we look at the
artistic expression of HLA F the
expression F became also almost drops to
a third between those two samples
furthermore if we look at the any two
four three eight five which is - cannot
stand again we observe again a
homozygous deletion here and the
comparable comparable expression value
to anyone threats emanate from
saint-jean which kind of slightly
indicates that maybe distribution has
something to do with the expression of
the hlaf gene but also with the usage of
the exons and they couldn't be
investigating this further because just
on those free samples is very hard to
compute anything so the wrap things up
to wrap things up the methods that are
introduced today to was ng/ml r which is
a long wait Knepper the mara script is
currently out in bio archive and the
software is freely available
github sniffles switches is our
observation detection tool for long
reads can also detect nested structure
events for example in version
the deletions or a word for tandem
duplication manuscript is together with
next-gen of alarm bio archive max
janitor short written applet we
developed over my PhD and what was
published in 2013 by or from Maddox and
is kind of heavily used it's a it's
available on github as well for free and
so why was the toolkit that be used for
simulating of structure burns of
relating structuration call sets and
comparing and merging structure and
within samples and across samples and
was published in 2017 energy
communications is also freely available
on my github site so in the end i want
to acknowledge and the human genome
sequencing center he had paid a college
of medicine especially my colleagues
will even Richards and Richard keeps
obviously Johns Hopkins my former Pio
Micra sheds and the whole shad slab for
their continuous help in collaborations
back in my PhD lab from the University
of Vienna for the bretschneider a fume I
did this study with the Longworth
mapping in the structure Beijing collar
more smoke goals will help to learn a
lot with decoding non from a low who is
the PI and of course NIH for generously
funding
thank you much thank you dr. C the check
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type in your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the segment well
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for it let's get started our
first question is how much coverage do
you recommend for the long and this is
indeed a very good question because like
it's about price and costs per study
I'll prepare the extra slide for that
but here we basically took to anyone to
hit seven eight which was 55 X
originally courage and subsampled it to
5 X 10 X 15 X 20 X and for DX we ran
then our methods and GML are and
sniffles was different coverage
parameters indicated in different colors
and when you fix the to have an 80%
recall
which is on the y-axis you can actually
get up to 80 85 percent of precision
indicated by 10 15 X coverage and also
when we look at sppf 3 a data set that I
haven't presented yet which is a breast
cancer cell line data said when we fixed
again the 80% position you can obtain
and slightly less than 8% recall over 15
X coverage and so these two datasets
represent that 10 X 15 X really is kind
of the sweet spot I wouldn't go below
that because that would mean that you
have 5 reads or less per haplotype and
also since the coverage is a Poisson
model basically also for these long
reads you end up having the risk of much
more regions having no coverage at all
okay our next question is these long
range technologies are known to have
high error rates this is a problem for
applications like SNP calling etc right
that's an interesting question so yes
but bio as well as nanopore as a high of
sequencing our rates of 10% or even
above that the good thing though is that
the sequencing error themselves are
randomly distributed which means with 5x
coverage or 10x coverage we often can
obtain a high accuracy in terms of snip
calling and of course with higher
coverage levels than that the Korean
economy is even higher and we are
currently preparing a manuscript for a
new snip collar that can nourish as long
reads technologies and that's this will
Fred into an effort to get this
comprehensive genome stressed by over
long reads because then we will be able
to not just call structure grants and
accurately map those reads
but also consonant as variants thank you
another question we have here asks where
do you see the application of these long
reads or clinical applications right I
mean right now we have we have to have
the trend of having the short key
technologies into clinics especially
over X and C
one thing which is very inexpensive and
since they have low sequencing error
rates the precision of snip calls in
this excellent region is also very
interesting
whoa ball I think we will see that I
think capture essays will make it the
first will make the first wave into this
clinics which shows a inexpensive and
fast way to obtain these long reads in
certain targeted change regions to
identify structure rounds and snips of
hot recessed region we are trust having
a three point up for GPA for Parkinson
disease and we're being used a nine KB
capture array using nanopore to identify
snips and structure rounds
what is disease in a certain region
works generally hard to assess
variability with the Illumina data and
we could validate all the snip calls and
all the structure being caused by
previously known literature and that we
obtained over this data sets and just
had one false discovered snip hair
sample okay we have time for one more
question and this one says comprehensive
genomes are great how far along are
methods to leverage these informations
right so as a percent of today basically
what you obtain out is a typically face
genome with the Buried sequence and so
not just one fastest pass to five or two
unfortunately there are not many methods
right now that can leverage this
information I know that for example star
which is our Nasik liner and it's
modified towards that it can leverage
both haplotype information to map this
RNA seek data the challenge here is if
you have this haplotype a soft data is
that each region is represented
basically twice because you have to have
no types and therefore the concept of
mapping qualities is not anymore true
because like mapping qualities represent
if you read can be mapped uniquely or
not in the whole genome so this needs
further computational and algorithmic
development to really cope with these
challenges in the new future
I would like to once again thank dr.
Sela check for his presentation I would
also like to thank Bob roots for making
today's education the webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for an on-demand viewing through August
of 2018 you will receive an email from
labyrinth letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now if they
need for joining us we hope to see you
again soon
goodbye